hey everybody this is Scott here to tell
you a little bit about Watch Dogs 2
which is getting a bunch of new content
in April for people who want to pay a
little bit of money the no compromis DLC
is going to add a new single player
mission called Moscow Gambit as well as
a few time trials and new gear for
everyone else there's going to be a free
content update that includes Motocross
drone and x-cart racing as well as
several new PVP modes called Showdown
which we're going to show you a little
bit of in this clip if you want more be
sure to like And subscribe and head to
gamespot.com whoa
Officer Down Squad be advised that a
possible suspect or suspects have been
reported near your
location Su
shooting careful Patrol he's heading
right for
you you're outnumbered give
[Applause]
up
take Squad we have aerts of hostile in
your
area
[Music]
I
h
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
a
no
[Music]
h